hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft fakes und
zwar möchte ich diesmal gar nicht lange
drum rumreden hier vorher der erste weg
wird mit zugesendet von robin ist ein
sehr sehr geil effekt und allgemein
denke ich dass alle facts sich in dieser
folge vorstellen werde dass ihr die
eigentlich alle noch nicht kennen sollte
bzw ein paar leute werden jetzt sagen
ich konnte wieder alles und das dorf und
das jetzt sofort dass du ja gar keine
richtigen facts also erstmal alles in
minecraft auch infekt wäre ja wenn ich
mit linksklick auf dem blog schlage
gitter kaputt aber die prozent anzahl
wäre die infect halt schon kennt zeit
anders naja egal welche anfang mai
direkt an und zwar dass hier ein ganz
normaler baum den man da so hin so sieht
ein ganz normaler bauern aus wenn man
allerdings hier ich habe so ein kleines
testfläche hier angelegt wäre ich hab da
so ein paar grasbüschel eingesetzt legen
und darum sondern seinen glas blog kreuz
wenn ich dir jetzt hier somit knochen
pulver knochen baut bäume anpflanzen
kann ich euch sagen dass also es
beansprucht sehr viele versuche
allerdings ich habe jetzt gar nur drei
gebraucht das ist relativ kalt ich habe
ein bisschen viel schon aufgebaut
es kommen nur so riesige bäume oder
allgemein bäume mit einer anderen s k s
kann es kommt nie sein otto normal baur
aus zeigen jetzt hier wird
wahrscheinlich jetzt kein baum raus
kommen weil er direkt daneben steht hier
könnte es vielleicht ja aber er hat auf
jeden fall auch eine andere form als
dieser baum dahinter sind dahin ist an
normale standard baum ich kann euch
sagen wenn ich noch mal so einen
komischen baum gesetzt würde wird er
genauso aus dem video oder so ein
bisschen anders vielleicht ist dieses
gras die innenstadt da oder so so ganz
normale chillige sachen allerdings ist
der hier auch schon wieder eine andere
konstellation im baum eine andere
struktur wenn ich die noch mal mehr
nehme hier ist wieder so ein riesiger
baum das wird so heftig sein wenn ich
das gleiche da alles abbauen muss da es
auch wieder sondern sondern so ein
komisches ding sowieso vorne nur einen
block höher soll ich mach mal hier ich
möchte euch nochmal einen riesigen baum
zeigen weil zu 99 prozent oder zu 90
prozent keine ahnung wie hoch genau die
prozentzahl ist da kommt endlich mal ein
heftiger riesen baumhaus lang 1 robin
für diesen heftigen fällt also wenn ihr
einen baum fahren haben wollt mir zu
heftigen bäumen und dann irgendwie sowas
machen wollte macht euch auf jeden fall
so was gab's jetzt hier
hier kommt eigentlich dürfte nichts mehr
raus kommen weil das eigentlich direkt
daneben steht ja genau
es kommen wirklich fast immer so heftig
riesige beim raw 17.5 sachen gemacht
dass kam dreimal sind heftiger riesiger
baum aus also
sind echt klasse bäume die hier
rauskommen ich hab noch nie so heftige
bäume gesehen das sind zuerst und alle
zutaten sind nicht das ist ein baum
das ist mega krass also dank an robin
für diesen effekt nicht sagen wir machen
direkt mit dem nächsten fängt so freunde
der zweite weg kommt von niklas und zwar
besagt dieser fake dass ich wenn ich auf
seelen sind rum gehe und dann auf eine
treppe zu laufen dass sich dann nicht
die treppe hoch laufen kann und zwar
geht das ja es geht auch nicht sonst
würde ich das nicht vorstellen also und
zwar seht ihr das schon wenn ich so auf
den seelen sand zu laufen
ich gehe so ein bisschen nach unten ich
bin in den sand drin wenn ihr seht meine
meine füße sind zwei pixel hoch zwei
pixel im skin ich gehe zwei pixel mehr
oder weniger nach unten so ein blog ist
glaube ich sechzehn pixel groß und da
bin ich halt zwei pixel unter diesem
link und deswegen kann ich die treppe
nicht hoch laufen
wenn ich allerdings jetzt mal momente
die man jetzt könnte eine richtige
wieder vernünftig wenn ich jetzt eine
treppe hinsetzen würde dann welche halt
nicht in den boden drin und die treppe
besteht somit aus einem halben blog
deswegen gar nicht die hoch laufen wenn
ich allerdings nur einen pixel darunter
bin kann ich die treppe nicht mehr hoch
laufen also das ist dann quasi wie sonne
wie so eine wand
das heißt dementsprechend könnte ja ich
kann halt nur hoch hüpfen ihr könnt das
so als weiß nicht als abgrenzung nehmen
oder irgendwie sowas oder keine ahnung
also wenn ich auf sand laufen kann ich
keine treppen hoch laufen so freundin
die nächste feld wurde mit zugesendet
von ul und was ist auch ein weg von dem
ich denke dass er dennoch nicht kennen
so wie bei jedem fällt eigentlich diese
folge und zwar kann ich einfach nochmal
pilze kühl erschaffen und zwar wenn ich
jetzt mal eine schere auf die pilz kühe
drauf gehen wird die pilze zu einer
normalen code ich bekomme genau fünf
pilze von ihr
also ich werde jetzt im nachhinein 15
pilze haben moment titels bei die braut
noch so 15 kürzer habe ich jetzt ich
kann das bei jeder kuh machen hier zack
zack und die kuh entwickelt sich um
barbara also wenn ich eine pizza habe
und gehe mit einer schülerin damit diese
pilze zu einer normalen so freunde
kommen wir nun zum fun fact in dieser
folge und zwar das feuer was ihr in den
mai kreft spiel hört also dass hier
ist in wirklichkeit auch echtes feuer
also die mitarbeiter von mojang haben da
wirklich echtes feuer angezündet und
haben das einfach dann so gefiel mit
genentech nehmen das dann irgendwie
bearbeitete da irgendwie sowas als wenn
ich mal hier jetzt nämlich einfach sogar
einstelle
das ist echtes feuer und ich finde das
hört man auch also das war diesmal der
fun feldmann lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat nicht denke ich hoffe
einfach mal dass ich nichts von den
verletzten menge kritik an von bekannten
wir alle schon jetzt wollen wir
allerdings wieder coole sachen
zugesendet die immer konkreter gmail.com
instagram dot com / laser luca steht
auch immer oben in der beschreibung
jetzt weil er irgendwie auffällig
unterwegs in dieser instagram dot com /
bonn kraft aus dem feld hat erfordert in
die paysafecard an dafür dass man mit
dem irgendwie weiß nicht keine ahnung
hero aufnehmen darf genauso wie auf
skikes und ips auch kontrapunkt official
oder konkreter prix wartet also der ist
auch in faker also ich habe meine nicht
komplett anders dabei miteinander
geredet und nidda gefunden
uwe völker die paysafecard haben wollen
dafür dass die hero kommt das ist alles
fake glaubt den leuten nicht und sonst
hoffe ich dass ihr alles bisher jetzt
bisher so dazu gelernt habe was ich ihr
euch so genannte habe dass ein paar
tipps tricks haus gefunden habt und dann
würde ich sagen wenn es euch wirklich
gefallen hat dann lasst einfach eine
bewertung dar
das zeigt mir dass es euch halt ja
dementsprechend nach eurem empfinden wie
es euch gefallen hat ich finde das
eigentlich so viel klima bevor es meiner
welt abgebrannt als ich diese ganzen
bäume angeht so ist das irgendwie weiß
nicht was cool